[Music]
be a top shot i think it's an incredible
project for a million reasons
i also think it's an incredibly
interesting project because i think a
lot of people can lose a lot of money
not because top shot's doing anything
wrong rohan is incredibly thoughtful
it's that those are more like sports
cards they'll be the next one in the
next year and the next year and i know
what kevin garnett
and chris paul and tim duncan and
patrick ewing rookie cards go for
there's not a sustainability to top shot
long term i'm very concerned of how big
that crash will be especially because
it's by far the biggest project for the
normal consumer does that
hurt quote unquote the space it may yeah
this is why we have to educate and say
things like this i think it's so cool
basketball the best culture but i'm also
a monster fan of sports cards but i'm
out there saying all the time that if
you buy rookies and not lebron and
jordan
you're gonna somebody's gonna be held
with the bag are you gonna get hurt